the chaos at our Southern border
continuing into the new year Customs and
Border Protection sources revealing to
Fox News a staggering new record number
of migrants entering our country in just
the month of December and at the same
time a massive migrant Caravan is
marching its way through Mexico welcome
back everyone to a special edition of
Fox News Live I'm Anita vogle in Los
Angeles and Rich great to be with you
and happy New Year happy New Year great
to be with you Anita I'm riched in New
York border officials say they
encountered a new record of
302,000 migrants in December and more
than double that since October 1st the
unprecedented figures have some
democratic lawmakers pushing President
Biden to address this
crisis the pull factor right now is that
as long as people are coming to the
border and they feel that they're hidden
a speed bump and then they're being
released and waiting four five six years
for an adjudication
then they're going to keep coming it's
the pull factor if we don't address that
by addressing detention giving them the
the quick hearing and then deporting
most of them are going to be deported
because Asylum cases if you look at the
last 25 years 87% are going to be uh
rejected so why are we allowing 100%
when we ought to be looking at smaller
points
so uh let's get more with this with
former ice director and former Federal
prosecutor Jonathan fahe uh you know
Jonathan uh if you look at what's going
on here and what uh Congress is
negotiating here what happens from here
do you think there's much that Congress
can do to address this no I really don't
because really the core problem as I see
it is the administration's lack of will
or lack of Desire whatsoever to enforce
the existing law you know Congressman
qua are is right they are encouraging
people to come here here with the pull
factor and and where I think he's
mistaken is even when they do get these
Asylum hearings 6 7 8 n years down the
road if we have an Administration
similar to this Administration they're
not going to be deported this
administration's stated policy is they
only Deport the most serious criminals
con that have to be convicted so people
that are not getting Asylum or not
showing up for hearings or otherwise are
not even being deported I think there's
over a million people that have orders
of deportation and this Administration
is doing nothing to deport them so
people know once they get here assuming
political winds do not change in this
country they are staying here and they
in effect are treated as good or better
than citizens in many cases you Jonathan
this is so rare especially when you look
at the month of December typically it's
not as busy at the southern Border in
this month and now we've hit a record of
all months of any year at least from
what we've recorded in history so what
does 2024 look like I think think it's
going to be more of the same or in fact
worse you know you you have that 300,000
number but that doesn't even count the
Goda ways and the known Goda ways which
you know typically that could be 60 to
70,000 a month but I think you know
people when they're looking at this they
know once they get here they get to stay
they also are going to know that there's
an election coming up and things might
change so I think this in the incentive
is going to be tremendous for this year
for people to come here the cartels know
it the human Smugglers know it so this
year will be more of the same and this
Administration isn't planning on doing
anything about it there's plenty they
can do but they're unwilling to you know
Buck their party on this issue uh and
you see all the problems in New York and
Chicago but they're going to remain and
they'll they'll try to make a political
issue and say they're trying to do
something about it with Comprehensive
immigration reform and these other
things but those really just amount to
to amnesty when you really break those
things down with what they're actually
seeking to have done you know Jonathan
you look at the hundreds of thousands of
people just this month alone who've
basically surrendered themselves to
Customs and Border Protection they walk
up they apply for Asylum they're
released into the country usually given
a notice to appear now several years or
a couple of years into the future but
what about those who who circumvent any
type of American Authority on their way
into the country is American law
enforcement eventually tracking some
people who get here I mean how open is
this yeah that's a really good point the
people that don't come through the
Border they're actually even better off
under this administration's policy
because nobody's tracking them and this
Administration has been quite clear
being here illegally is not a basis to
be removed they will not remove them at
all the only scenario they'll be removed
would be if they are convicted of a
serious felony or somehow found to be a
national security threat which is going
to be very rare so those people that
evade any sort of you know reporting or
anything really are going to live here
as long as they want assuming the
political situation is the same and
nobody's looking for them and you know
they're not even you know it's so
extreme you know the democrat's position
they don't even want to deport criminals
we have these Sanctuary cities this
Administration could do something to
crack down on that when they've they
don't even address it or say anything
negatively about it so people that are
here are going to stay with this
political environment Jonathan fahe the
former ice director Jonathan thanks so
much
thank you hey it's Will Kane click here
to subscribe to the Fox News Channel on
YouTube it's the best way to get our
latest interviews and highlights and
click to subscribe to the will cane
podcast for full episodes right now